so Andy tell us about your film dick
night motuc nights about a young woman
who has been left at the altar and is in
you know the midst of a heartbroken
depression and she decides on this one
particular night that she's going to get
over it and so she goes about you know
finding the right guy to have a
one-night stand with and ends up you
know with too many suitors for the deed
and then also at her house at in the
middle of the desert with some may be
unwanted visitors who might be vampires
and so you know that's the basic setup
for for what happens on this one night
in the movie so what prompted you to
make it you're the writer director yeah
you know it's what it's one of these
ideas i think that originates really
with a location and knowing that I could
go and and use this this house that was
kind of out in the middle of the desert
in Tucson Arizona that I could go out
there and take it over for a little
while and shoot a movie and so of course
you know house out in a remote spot
horror is probably the first thing that
comes to mind but I'm not at heart I
Wednesday a horror writer director you
know much more in comedy based material
and so you know that I sort of push that
aside and then went to the comedy parts
of it and came up with this story about
this woman who you know it had gotten
left at the altar was looking for
one-night stand but you know the horror
part just wouldn't leave and I was still
attracted to it or even felt like you
know I have this house it's kind of
stupid not to use it for what it feels
like it would be good for and you know I
had been you know influenced by a
certain movies that I did kind of like
the you know there hasn't been a ton of
them i guess that movies that have a
real shift in tone or
rection that you know comes a little out
of nowhere and so that was how I started
to build this you know comedy that takes
a hard turn into [ __ ] territory or
comedy horror or horror comedy really
going something kind of a comedy that
turns into a horror comedy for a bit
you